الوقوف هنا قبل سنوات كان مستحيلا فمياه
البحر الميت كانت تغمر المكان لكن معالم
تبخره باتت واضحه اضافه لدراسات تؤكد
اختلاف المشهد كليا بعد 50 عاما فالبحر
الميت مهدد بالاختفاء مع دلالات انكماشه
بمعدل متر من كل عام والبحث عن حلول
لانعاشه بات ضروره القصوى
شواطئ تسحرت بعد تبخر المياه التي كانت
تغمرها على مر سنوات انحسار البحر الميت
ارتبط بعده اسباب اهمها تحويل اسرائيل
لمياه نهر الاردن عن مجراه الطبيعيه
المنصب فيه ومع فشل العديد من المشاريع
الهادفه لانقاذ البحر الميت باتت الحلول
تتجه لاعاده تاهيل مياه نهر الاردن الذي
يعد رافدا اساسا للبحر الميت مساء كان
اخرها اعلان النوايا بين الجانبين الاردني
والاسرائيلي تنصب حول الاهتمام بنهر
الاردن واعاده تاهيله من خلال خطط ودراسات
لم يعلن عنها بعد حتى الان يعني هو اتفاق
مبدئي بهدف تحديد الاليات والوسائل
المخصصات من قبل المجتمع الدولي للتمويل
هذا المشروع الذي يصب في مصلحه المنطقه
خلال 20 عاما تقريبا بحسب الخبراء خاصه مع
اعت على الهطول المطريه فقط كرافد له لا
يتجاوز باحسن حالاته المئتي مليون متر
مكعب سنويا مقارنه بما كان عليه الحال قبل
تحويل مياه نهر الاردن ما يشرح حاليا
حوالي 150 مليون متر مكعب في العام بين ما
كان سابقا من كل الروافد وكل المناطق
حوالي 1800 مليون متر مقابل
ذلك
للبحر الميت بات الحل الوحيد لاسعافه او
الحفاظ على منسوبه الحالي ان امكن وما بين
مشاريع عضويه واعلان النوايا الجديده تؤكد
الحقائق اهميه البدء الفعلي بخطوات جاده
لانقاذ البحر الميت
العربيه من البحر الميت